مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وفيها نناقش ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه من الاطفال وما يعانونه من صدمات
جسديه ونفسيه لمناقشه هذا الملف سيكون
معنا من واشنطن الكساندرا سايح رئيسه قسم
السياسات الانسانيه بمنظمه انقذوا الاطفال
قبل النقاش نستعرض بعض الارقام الخاصه
بالضحايا الاطفال في قطاع غزه اذ تقول
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان طفلا واحدا يقتل
كل عر دقائق في قطاع غزه بينما تقول منظمه
الامم المتحده للطفوله اليونيسيف ان قطاع
غزه اصبح اخطر مكان للاطفال في العالم حيث
ان لدى اليونيسيف
340 ال طفل دون سن الخامسه وهم من اكثر من
يعانون من سوء التغذيه واشارت الى ان اكثر
من ث 800 ال طفل نزحوا من منازلهم ويعيشون
ظروفا بيئيه صعبه في مراكز الايواء
المقتضى واشارت الى ان نحو 1000 طفل
تعرضوا لبتر في الاطراف جراء الحرب على
القطاع نعود لضيفنا من واشنطن الكساندرا
سايح رئيسه قسمه قسم السياسات الانسانيه
بمنظمه انقذوا الاطفال مرحبا بك سيده
الكساندرا مثل هذه الارقام وهذه ال
معلومات والمعطيات لما يعايش الاطفال
قتل انتشال من تحت الانقاض ضمن هذه
التجربه منهم من هم جرحى منهم من بترت
اطرافهم وشاهدنا العدد اكثر من 1000 طفل
في قطاع غزه منهم من فقدوا اقرانهم او
عائلاتهم او فقدوا كل العائله كيف يمكن
للاطفال ان لا
يطوروا مشاكل وصدمات نفسيه مع ما يعانونه
ايضا من
الجوع شكرا نعم بالفعل من الاهميه بمكان
ان نتحدث عن هذه المسائل الاساسيه ما نراه
في قطاع غزه هو قتل غير مسبوق للاطفال حتى
بالمقارنه مع اكثر النزاعات دمويه في
العالم تقريبا نصف كل السكان الذين قتلوا
في قطاع غزه هم من الاطفال ونعرف ان
الالاف من الاطفال لا يزالون تحت الركام
وبالتالي الاشخاص الذين لم يقتلوا بسبب
القصف يخاطر بهم الان بان يموتوا هؤلاء
الاطفال بسبب الامراض والمجاعه وبالاضافه
الى ذلك نرى ان الاطفال والعائلات يزج بهم
في اماكن ضيقه واصغر واصغر من حيث المساحه
وهي ليست امنه في قطاع غزه حتى قبل
التصعيد الاخير قبل احداث السابع من
اكتوبر الاطفال في قطاع غزه كانوا يعيشون
في ظروف صعبه بعد 16 سنه من الحصار
العسكري المفروض على قطاع غزه وعانى
الاطفال من حالات تصعيد متعدده للعنف
وبالنسبه الى منظمه انقذ الاطفال من خلال
عملنا في قطاع غزه وجدنا ان معظم او
اكثريه الاطفال يعانون من كوابيس في الليل
وليس لديهم امل بالمستقبل وفي الاسابيع
السبع السبعه او ثمانيه الماضي نرى ان
الوضع سوف يصبح اسوا بسببها ولذلك من
الاهميه بما كانان ان المجتمع الدولي يدعم
بشكل فوري وقفا لاطلاق النار لحمايه
الاطفال وحمايه العائلات من العنف وايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه الملحه لابقاء الناس
على قيد
الحياه ابقي معنا سيده الكساندرا نتابع
حسن وفاطمه طفلان تغيرت حياتهما تماما ما
تعرض له الطفلان من صدمات جسديه ونفسيه
ينقل تفاصيلها المؤثره ينقل تفاصيلها
المؤثره في هذا التقرير ليعكس حال عشرات
الالاف من الاطفال الذين يعيشون ما يمكن
وصفه بفعل العدوان المستمر على قطاع غزه
نشاهد هذا التقرير ثم نتابع
النقاش
حبشه لما قالوا ابن عمي رفيق
مصاب ولسه مش معروف مين هو ولما جيت على
المستشفى عرفت انه حسن زعلت كثير لانه هو
احلى واحد في
اخواته والحلو دائما
حلو هو بحب يشرب عصير كثير كل ما يصيح
يقول بدي عصير وكل ما يشرب
بسكت احنا كنا في البيت
قاعدين فجا ما لقينا غير الدار هي اللي
علينا طلعت هذا من تحت
الانقاض بعد ما انا طلعت طلعت اخوي بتاعت
الانقاض لقيت لوح زينجو قص كعبه من تحت
شلته وضنا على
المستشفى ما كان المستشفى يعني في
مستشفيات كان كمال عدوان فقط بس شغال
وتغرز حكم ب غرزها على الوسا قت لا حكمك
تطلع الاوروبي استنت اول يوم الهدنه انا
قبل الهدنه بيوم ان قصفت او يومين يومين
وطلعت على الاوروبي لما جيت هنا لو قال
رجل فيها شويه التهابات ق بد عمليه تنظيف
لما نظفوا العمليه وكشفوا على العظم في
احتاجت لبتر
يعني دائما بتوجع بج وبلته انا ف هو مش
راضي يلعب هلقيت معاي زعلان العب معي يا
حسون ما اشتره شاطر هذا الولد بحبه انا
دائما للعب معاي كثير بس بضله يتوجع بجره
وبصير
يعيط كان كثير حلو الطفل وكنت اجي عنده
واقعد عنده والعب معه وكمان كنت اجي عنده
كان كنا نروح على البحر مع بعض حص صح يا
حسون كان يلعب في الشارع وكان اخوه محمود
نجح كان يجري في الشارع ويقول اخوي نجح
اخوي نجح وكان يحب برضه انه يحل الواجب مع
اخوه علي وهو في
الروضه كان برضه شاغب بس امه بس مشاغبات
صغيره بس ققول لي محمد اشتري لي العاب
ققول له حاضر جبت له
هذ قت لي اياها هي هديه
هذه يطلع ف مستغرب ايش اللي صير في انا
حتى هو مش فاهم ايش صير فيه بوللي انا
يعني قبل سالته ايش صار في رجلك ققول رحت
على العمليات سويت عمليه في رجلي بس وين
رجلي
يركبوها فاطمه اللي احنا بدلعها بطه ف بطه
هذه كانت قبل ما تتصاب
احلى بنت واشطر بنت وتشارك تروح على
الروضه وتلعب وتنبسط بعد الاصابه طفت زي
ما انتم شايفين طافيه لا ضحكه ولا لعبه
ولا بتحكي مع حدا ولا بترد على حدا تنسيق
الكلام عندها ضرب مش قادر تنسق كلام او
تعبر عن ايش هي ايش في عندها طبعا يوم ما
طلعناها بط بقت وضعها يعني رجلها من حدت
الهان كان الاصابه
ولكن ضغط احتلال على المستشفيات وقله
الرعايه وقله الادوات والمواد وضغط
الاصابات الكثيره تسبب لها بالتهابات
فتسبب بقطع الرجل كلها وهينا اليوم في
مستشفى الاوروبي اننا ست سبعه ايام نستنى
نعالجها ونخلص علاجها ونشوف
كيف سيده الكساندرا تابعنا هذا التقرير
المؤثر فعلا ل حياه الطفلين حسن وفاطمه
ومثلهم الاف تعرضوا لصدمات جسديه ونفسيه
كيف يمكن
مساعده او ما هي مستويات المساعده
المطلوبه ان كان للطفل وان كان ايضا
للعائله وما نوعها كي تستطيع يعني تجاوز
ما تعيشه في المدى الحالي والمدى المتوسط
والمستقبل
نحن نستمع الى قصص مماثله في كل الوقت هذا
هو
واقع الحال في الاطفال بالنسبه اللاطفال
في قطاع غزه العائلات تمزق وهناك الكثير
من الاولويات نحن بحاجه الى مساعدات من
حيث الطعام بالاضافه الى دعم اجتماعي نفسي
وقدره على الوصول الى الماء النظيف 70% من
سكان قطاع غزه ليس لديهم قدره على الوصول
الى الماء النظيف وهذا يؤدي الى انتشار
الاوبئه والامراض نحن بحاجه الى توزيع
المساعدات في الاماكن المختلفه من قطاع
غزه العائلات المتواجده في الشمال من
القطاع لم تحصل على اي مساعدات لاسابيع
ولذلك هذا امر ملح نحن بحاجه الى ايصال
المساعدات الى كل اجزاء قطع غزه ولكن ما
يحصل الان هو ان المساعدات محدوده للغايه
والمساعدات التي تصل هي غير كافيه بتاتا
نحن نرى ان اسعار ماكولات ترتفع بشكل كبير
حلقت الاسعار حتى كيس الطحين وصل الى 140
دولار وبالتالي العائلات ليس باستطاعتها
ان تشتري الطعام ما من شيء متاح في
الاسواق المستشفيات انهارت بشكل كامل ما
من قدره على الوصول الى الادويه بالنسبه
اليها الامر صعب للغايه بالنسبه الى
المنظمات الانسانيه ان تقدم المساعده
وتبدا
بالمساعده للاطفال لكي يتخطوا بعض الصدمات
التي عانوا منها في خلال استمرار عمليه
القصف في انحاء قطاع الغزه المختلفه حتى
العائلات لا تشعر بالامان لكي تذهب الى
اماكن توزيع المساعدات ونحن نواجه صعوبات
في توزيع هذه المساعده لذلك النقطه
الاساسيه والاهم هي ضروره وقف الاعمال
الفيه وقف القصف وان تعيد اسرائيل فتح كل
المعابر وترفع الحصار عن قطاع غزه كي
نتمكن من ايصال المساعدات الملحه للعائلات
ولكي تتمكن العائلات من الوصول الى
المساعدات والخدمات الاساسيه من مثل الماء
والطعام والوقود كيف ترين مستقبل الاطفال
وهم الذين تعرضوا الى كل هذا العنف وكل
هذه الصدمات خاصه بان هذا النوع من
الصدمات من الممكن ان تختزل في اللا شعور
لدى الاطفال وما ستكونه لاحقا في حياتهم
يبقى يعني نتيجه هذه الصدمات التي كونوها
في اللا شعور في
الصغر نعم بالفعل كما تفضلت الاطفال في
قطاع غزه اذا ما كان الطفل في سن السادس
عش يكون قد شهد تصعيدا مكررا للعنف
العسكري
والحصار حتى الاطفال الاقل سنا عانوا من
نفس الامور وهذه التجارب تبقى ملازمه
للاطفال لفتره طويله ولكن الاطفال
باستطاعتهم ان يتعافوا ويستعيد العافيه
اذا ما حصلوا على الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي
لمواجهه هذه الصدمات ولكن ما نراه ان هناك
غياب تام للمؤشرات التي تفيد بان العنف
سوف يتوق
في القريب العاجل لذلك نجدد الدعوه الى
وقف لاطلاق النار للسماح للمنظمات
الانسانيه ان توصل المساعدات للاطفال
وللعائلات لكي تتعامل مع هذه الصدمه وتبدا
مرحله التعافي الان هذا غير ممكن حتى ان
العائلات لا تعرف ما اذا كان باستطاعتها
ان تصل الى الطعام او الى الماء النظيف او
اذا ما كان لديها مشاغل اصلا مرتبطه بامن
وبسلامه ولذلك نحن بحاجه الى ضمان السلامه
للاطفال وهذا غير ممكن الان مع استمرار
القصف لذلك نحن بحاجه الى وقف فوري لاطلاق
النار شكرا لك شكرا لك الكسانرا سايح
رئيسه قسم السياسات الانسانيه بمنظمه
انقذوا الاطفال حدثتنا من واشنطن شكرا على
المشاركه معنا وقبل نهايه هذه النافذه
نشير بان حصيله العدوان الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه بلغت
18 خمسه شهداء بينما بلغ عدد المصابين
اكثر من
4965 ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه
بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على غزه